sur le fondement de l'article 49 alinéa
3 de la Constitution j'engage la
responsabilité de mon gouvernement sur
la première partie du projet de loi de
finance pour 2024 on est évidemment pas
surpris par le 493 mais il y a quand
même une surprise c'est que le
gouvernement innve même en matière de
493 parce que je crois pas qu'on ait
déclenché un 493 un jour sur un budget
avant même qu'on ait commencer l'examen
des articles 493 c'est évidemment un
échec un échec à construire des
consensus ce que j'ai dit d'ailleurs
avec les parlementaires de mon groupe
hier la première ministre et il n'est
pas question pour nous de d'accepter
qu'on puisse continuer à banaliser le
493 comme d'ailleurs peut-être demain la
motion de censure si les républicains ne
censurent pas le gouvernement avec cette
motion de censure s'ils ne dépose pas
eux-mêmes une motion de censure ou s'il
ne soutiennent pas la motion de censure
que pourrait déposer le rassemblement
national ça voudra dire que les
républicains une fois encore laissent
passer ce budget donc que les républ
soutiennent les Hauses d'impôts que les
républicains soutiennent l'endettement
que les républicain soutiennent ce
gouvernement donc les faux semblant des
républicains moment ça suffit je
rappelle que l'année dernière ils
avaient dit aux Français on soutient le
budget du gouvernement parce qu'on a on
a une promesse d'un carburant à 1,50 €
donc le gouvernement été sauvé par les
républicains les Français n'ont jamais
vu de carburant 1,50 le l à l'ouverture
de ce débat budgétaire le gouvernement
lors des dialogues de ver nous avait
laissé comprendre qu'il aurait cette
fois-ci une vision un peu plus ouverte
du débat bud c'estd que certes il
utiliserait certainement le 493 je l'ai
dit je considère déjà ça comme
condamnable mais que il serait peut-être
capable cette fois-ci
d'entendre de l'opposition et même
d'entendre l'Assemblée nationale de
manière
globale des propositions majoritaires
pour modifier son texte il n'en a rien
été le groupe français soumise a décidé
bien évidemment de déposer une notion de
censure si on considère que d'un point
de vue débat les 40 he qui ont eu lieu
en commission ne servent à rien alors
maintenant il faut supprimer aussi les
commissions dans notre assemblée je suis
désolé mais il y a eu un vrai débat
pendant 4 jours entiers il y a eu 2300
amendements qui ont été débattus qui ont
été examinés qui ont été votés ou pas
d'ailleurs et donc à partir de ce
travail-là le travail qui a été fait
dans le cadre du 493 a été différent et
a été influencé par tous les débats qui
ont eu lieu en commission